where did we start to lose that I mean
obviously religion was something that
was big that kept people in like a
common out like a common practice right
that was a and that was bigger in the
past centuries I feel like there has
been here in America yeah well I mean
and that provided a place where you
would go together you would there were
certain practices that you guys did each
week and uh there were you know
religious get-togethers and and and
people thinking about their God and
thinking with their god
um and singing together yes singing
together stuff like that it's powerful
man I've been in a I've been in a church
where people will start even in an
audience with a band sometimes and but
it's specifically at a church sometimes
people start singing It's like it'll
open up you know it'll make you feel
connected you know your feelings will
just start crying just start emoting you
know or feeling something yeah
um so there's something about that the
the doing something as a community and
feeling as a group yeah and also there's
the horizontal and like in some of the
practices that that we do
um there's the horizontal like you and I
reciprocally open to each other but
there's also the vertical you and I sort
of we're not only opening this way we're
opening vertically uh as well and it's
really interesting when you do some of
these uh Socratic practices uh dialectic
into diologos philosophical Fellowship
things like that people who are often
not religious at all secular they'll get
into this and they'll start to feel that
Collective Flow State and that sense of
reciprocally opening to each other and
then they all start talking about like
the the third the we space like the the
collective intelligence that neither
it's not coming just from you or for me
but it's being co-created and emerging
and taking on a life of its own yeah
right and then they start to talk about
this in in religious language and and we
we lost that I mean so that feels like
as close as we can get to God a lot of
times I feel like there's the best
people start saying things like that it
might be God for them and I I want to be
really careful here I'm very respectful
of people's religious adherence I'm not
anti-religious by any means
um but um no neither but people well
what happens is right and this is a a
platonic point a neoplatonic point so
what happens is
initially when they're doing these they
get an intimacy with each other that
reciprocal opening they fall in love
it's finally I love it's not right but
that's in the word philosophy it's
Fellowship love of wisdom right they get
that and then they start to feel
intimate with this the Geist the spirit
we call it the logos the the right this
this thing this emerging collective
intelligence that is making everything
more intelligible and people start to
reciprocally open with it right and then
they start to reciprocally open through
each other and through that logos to the
depths of reality yeah and then they
start to feel like they're in
relationship to what's his ultimate and
some people think about that as God and
and some and some people think about God
personally some people think about God
impersonally some people think about it
more like the ground of being or
Ultimate Reality but what everybody
starts well all the people that talk
this what they're doing is they're
trying to express
a connection to something that's
profoundly
transformatively real and meaningful and
we have a word for that it's sacred to
them now and there's a deep connection
between having a sacred canopy and the
cultivation of wisdom so another thing
I'll ask my student is where do you go
for information without thinking they
hold up their
smartphones because we're all cyborgs
now right right and I say where do you
go for knowledge and they'll sort of
like oh well science the university but
yeah something right but then I'll say
and this is where it's really
interesting where do you go for wisdom
and there's an anxious silence
now if you'd ask people that 200 years
ago they'd say oh my church my temple
my mosque right right right by Sanger
those answers don't come out
occasionally
very rarely somebody will say like my
church but sometimes they'll they'll say
kind of like but not really
and what's happened is
most so the the the largest demo growing
demographic are the nuns the n-o-n-e-s's
they have no affiliate official
religious identity now that doesn't mean
they're overwhelmingly atheist most of
them are spiritual but not religious or
Seekers or they have weird Supernatural
beliefs but so but
what's happened is most people are
abandoning religion not primarily
because they've come to some deep
conclusion that it's false although
religion has a problem the religions
generally have a problem with the
scientific worldview at least some
versions of them but it's much more it's
it's it's it's a little bit of a truth
issue you know but it's much more a
relevance issue most people feel that
these institutions are no longer like
relevant to them they're they're not
they're not vibrant they're not vital
yeah they they don't speak to them they
don't call them to their better self
they don't call them into like these
these the these these experiences in
fact the Ecology of practices has
generally withered and we've tended to
emphasize like giving each other
propositions and reciting them to each
other as opposed to
this complex set of rituals and colleges
and practices so yeah we as we lost and
I'm not and I'm not Nostalgia you can
put this on my Tombstone neither
Nostalgia nor Utopia I'm not Nostalgia
I'm not saying we need to go back right
right no we're just looking at it right
we're looking at it but when we lost
that sacred canopy we we lost a lot you
know Nietzsche said it really well he
said he runs into the marketplace The
Madman
and he's he doesn't confront Christians
he confronts the atheists who are all
sort of tittering about the death of God
and he said you don't know what and
Mitch is the guy who pronounces the
death of God so he's not he's not there
to argue against them as atheists he
said you don't realize what you've done
you've taken a sponge and you've wiped
out the sky right you've Unchained us
like we're no we're forever falling we
have to become worthy of this we like
killing God we have not like to put it
in affective terms we have not grieved
to the depths we need to and in a
healthy way in order to be worthy of
that that's what he's basically saying
well yeah it's like if you when you take
that type of thing away right I mean and
then you take away the religion of the
family right like a lot of families have
evolved you see a lot of single parent
families both parents have to work you
know the kids are being raised by uh you
know by their smart phones and by
whatever of the first thing you can get
to them and then you take away also you
know there was a time like in the 90s
where like uh everything kind of like
and this is a smaller version but
everything is like you can watch or
consume whatever you want when you want
it yeah there used to be like sure we
would have shared experiences they would
networks for a reason right we were to
network together we would all watch a
show and then we would go out on the
street and like impersonate the
characters from it we would uh like you
were excited as soon as the show went
was over especially in the summer
because it was still light outside we go
outside and like impersonate our
favorite acts from it we'd all laugh and
have like a shared experience we're
whereas now everybody was fragmented
yeah everybody's just like watching
whatever when they want it's all
separate you don't really feel a
connection I think that's that's
profoundly right that's what I meant
earlier about how popular culture used
to have a religious fun religio to bind
together it's we it used to do that and
now we've even lost that dimension